ich bin lena land ja nie ich bin 19
jahre alt und absolvierte gerade man den
grundwehrdienst bei der gala in wien
ich bin auch hauptberuflich schauspieler
das will ich im ausland aufgewachsen bin
und durch diese erfahrung habe ich
extrem viele charaktere kennen gelernt
das wiederum hat mich dazu inspiriert
schauspieler zu werden
also ich sehen war bin ich nach wien
gezogen und lebe seitdem in österreich
ich habe in dieser zeit mein land extrem
es zu schätzen gelernt
und deswegen bin ich sehr froh dass ich
gerade den grund der teams absolviere
ich hab so wir haben einen
grundwehrdienst bei der garde nicht sehe
sofort extrem viele zusammenhänge
zwischen schauspiel und parade
exerzieren parallelisieren genauso wie
schauspiel siehst du denn der uniform an
und bewegst dich in einem rhythmus und
diese erfahrung hat mir persönlich
extrem geholfen und deswegen bin ich
sehr froh dass ich ausgerechnet bei der
garde bin
man kennt mich aus filmen wie zum
beispiel maiberger oder soko donau
hauptsächlich aber aus dem film das
schaurige haus wurde daniel prohaska
regie geführt hat
mit diesem film bin ich tatsächlich auch
zum romy nominiert worden als beliebt
ist ein nachwuchsschauspieler 2021 es
würde mich extrem freuen wenn ihr für
mich wollten könnten unter ran.de /
voting
danke es ja